la droite ivelinoise face à un tournant
après une vingtaine d'années à la tête
du RPR de l'UMP puis des républicains 78
Pierre Bédier ne rempile pas pour un
nouveau mandat deux candidats se font
face pour devenir le nouveau président
de la fédération départementale des LR
Philippe benasaya et Hotman nasrou tous
deux vice-président des républicains des
Yvelines et élu localement Philippe
benasaya veut mettre son expérience à
contribution il a été maire de Bois
d'Arcy entre 2014 et 2020 et député des
Yvelines pendant 2 ans entre 2020 et
2022 l'auel vice-président du conseil
départemental est soutenu par Pierre
Bédier Pierre Bédier m'avait informé il
y a déjà des mois et des mois qu' ne qu'
qu'il arrêtait le le le le le le la
présidence des des républicains 78 et je
lui avais dit si c'est dans ce cas-là si
tu arrêtes je souhaiterais je
souhaiterais me présenter pour euh
continuer le travail mais renforcer la
dynamique et on en reparlera mais euh un
peu rajeunir les cadres et et trouver
des nouveaux moyens de milité parce que
parce que les républicains est sont un
parti classique conventionnel et c'est
vrai que quand on voit l'offre
aujourd'hui en France il y a des partis
qui ont adopté des des moyens de
militantisme beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
modernes face à lui Hotman naserou
proche de Valéri pcrè Présidente de la
Région Île-de-France dont il est l'un
des vice-présidents le conseil municipal
d'opposition à trrappe était déjà
candidat en 2018 au côté d'Alexandra
Dublanche il souhaite un renouvellement
au sein de la fédération moi quand j'ai
fait cette candidature s je l'ai fait
pour deux raisons d'abord parce que j'ai
considéré qu'il fallait absolument qu'on
refonde la droite que le travail à faire
était colossal et que l'idée qu'on
pouvait continuer comme avant sans rien
changer est une idée suicidaire pour la
droite qui va disparaître si on ne se
renouvelle pas et si on ne va pas au
bout d'un certain nombre de convictions
et donc j'ai été voir absolument tout le
monde y compris Philippe benasaya et
vraiment tous tous les grands élus de de
notre département pour leur présenter ma
démarche et j'ai tout de suite eu
beaucoup de soutien je souhaitais aussi
travailler avec tout le monde et je vous
le dis très simplement au lendemain de
cette élection si je suis élu je
travaillerai naturellement avec
absolument tout le monde le futur
président aura pour mission de donner un
nouveau souffle à la droite ivelinoise
en perte de vitesse de nombreux mares
les républicains encore mais aucune
circonscription décrochée lors des
dernières législatives et un nombre
d'adhérents en diminution dans le
département de 4600 en 2018 à près de
4000 aujourd'hui seuls les adhérents LR
voteront en ligne pour ce scrutin
interne programmé les 26 et 27 novembre